votre histoire votre pires crasses alors
j'avoue c'est pas bien à ne pas faire je
ne pars faire donc je pars en espagne à
barcelone
donc j'étais avec un ami même bateau
était parti pour faire la fête
une journée un peu comme l'était fou fou
et on arrive là bas on va dans un hôtel
pour la journée un jeu précise il y
avait une très belle piscine tout ça sur
le toile ne sera très bien les bus des
mots giteau balboa daudet maugis
théorisé pina colada et on rencontre des
jeunes gens sympathiques
alors on boit en bois on déjeune hors
bois bref on y passe la journée et au
moment de partir évidemment je vois la
note
la note 7 302 euros 302 302 euros
c'était pas le numéro de la chambre
non et alors justement jouer c'est un
petit peu cher quand même et le même
type arrive et me dit bêtement il me
donnait la note samedi
est ce que j'avais sur votre chambre et
moi j'étais vous je reconnais que
j'étais bourré c'est pas bien je dis je
dis bah oui oui s'il vous plaît oui
c'est intéressant c'est bourré pour la
107 1 et cet imbécile ou de me demander
mon nom il distance 7 et 10 pouces et à
trèbes et dire à monsieur régner j'ai
absolument c'est mieux régner et donc
iman et la note
j'ai signé et on sait tout paraît donc
on est en train d'apprendre que le
commissaire moulin se taper des tiers
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce qu'on veut la classe
d'isabelle morini-bosc on va le savoir
sur le sondage twitter alors oui ces
céréales appelé mais c'est pas non non
c'est pas plus 58 58 42 noms alors si ça
pousse et vous on va l'écouter
si vous merci vous aussi non
c'est le temps d'aller aux toilettes
vas-y j'avais très exactement sept ans
vachon attention tu me laisses que je
peux pas l'accepter
[Applaudissements]
18h18 115 10 815 oui alors oui d'où 4l
du 5 1 c'est waterloo
ah ouais merde et et j'avais eu le tort
de raconter que j'avais écoles faisait
du rachitisme on m'avait placé à la
campagne comme j'arrêtais pas de tomber
dans l'est dans les crottes on
m'appelait cp crottes de poule c'est une
manière de raconter ça il y avait une
petite garce en classe karité pas de
m'appeler crottes de poule contre ce
pool et j'en ai eu ras-le-bol qu'on me
font même un ras-le-bol à septembre donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qu'il a dit là comme on
s'en bat les couilles
mais moussa fall et vous demande donc
vous laisserai pas la fin pour après la
pub donc la cites avait un gros un
énorme chien et j'en avais tellement
marre un jour que j'ai ramassé vous
auriez dû le faire ou à cet âge là j'ai
ramassé toutes les crocs du chien
ouais je les ai conservé pendant 24
heures et le lendemain pendant qu'on
était on devait avoir gymnastique
je crois que dans ses chaussures dans
ses chaussures de tennis ce qui fait que
évidemment quand elle a glissé les pieds
dedans ce qui fait que j'ai été punie
par ma mère pas sa mère pana ce titre
m'a obligé à enfiler les chaussures
aller qui a trouvé cette histoire
intéressante à la vente de yens 1
franchement qu'il ya qui fait l'histoire
alors pas de passer tel n'est pas sa
meilleure